estos camiones acaban de llegar al paso
fronterizo de babalawa El único acceso
entre Turquía y el norte de Siria dentro
hay mantas y material para construir
refugios de emergencia una ayuda que
necesitan desesperadamente las víctimas
del terremoto
recientemente llegó un nuevo convoy de
ayuda de la ONU formado por 10 camiones
cargados con diversos suministros de
Socorro y materiales necesarios para
tiendas de campaña e higiene el jueves y
el viernes similares ya habían llegado a
zonas Rebeldes del Norte del país donde
viven más de 4 millones de personas pero
una semana después del desastre las
víctimas aún carecen de todo esto ha
provocado la ira de Los cascos blancos
los equipos de rescate que operan en las
zonas Rebeldes
[Música]
puedo decir que hasta ahora la ONU no ha
hecho nada
hoy he estado en una reunión con un
representante de la ONU y le he pedido
que se Disculpe ante el pueblo sirio
una llamada que fue escuchada por el
jefe de la agencia de ayuda de la ONU
hasta ahora hemos fallado a la población
del noroeste de Siria Con razón se
sienten abandonados buscan una ayuda
internacional que no ha llegado mi deber
y nuestra obligación es corregir este
fracaso tan rápido como podamos Ese es
mi objetivo ahora Turquía dice estar
trabajando para abrir otros dos pasos
fronterizos para facilitar la entrega de
la ayuda en cambio en zonas controladas
por el gobierno sirio hay un descargados
de ayuda humanitaria han aterrizado
desde la catástrofe pero en este país ya
asolado por la guerra según el alto
comisionado de las Naciones Unidas para
los refugiados más de cinco millones de
personas podrían quedarse sin un lugar
donde viviera a causa del terremoto